combined as many of your interest as
possible into your business because it
will help make you stand out from your
competition you'll have more fun you'll
get more customers coming in the door
and you increase the chance of being
successful because now you have a way to
stand out and be different against
everybody else in the market was doing
the same thing hi I'm Evan Carmichael I
believe that hungry entrepreneurs
deserve help and today maintained a
question from one of my readers nitesh
who wants to start a menswear design
company so he wrote in long email i'll
try to summarize he's been working for
three and a half years getting
experience as a fashion stylist he now
wants to start his own business in
menswear design he has an interest in
fashion styling designing architecture
film and you wanted to combine it all
into a menswear design company and one
of my advice on how to focus and which
one the to focus on how to get it to go
so the touch great question here's the
thing I don't want you to pick one or
the other I don't want you to pick being
a stylist or being a menswear designer
or going the architecture combine them
if you're going to start your own line
of clothing then combine all your
passions because that's what's going to
make your clothing different nobody else
out there is doing it the same way that
you could do it if you combine your love
of film architecture design and style
into a clothing line that's something
that people will resonate with that's
going to be different is going to be
unique that can help you stand out and
other people have the same interests
will want to buy what you have if you're
copying other people if you have similar
designs it's not going to help you stand
out so you have to combine all of your
passions into that one business to make
it amazing you'll have a lot more fun
because you're combining a lot of the
stuff that you love to do and it will
resonate with your customers and help
you stand out before jumping in though
I'd recommend getting some work done I
the company has already done this it's
great that you have some experience as a
stylist go work for a company who has
launched a clothing line get some
experience because I don't want to see
you drop thousands of dollars into this
project and not have a workout because
you don't have the experience so go work
for that company
me see how they launch their clothes
start your own thing on the side and
make it awesome and pour all of yourself
into it and for anybody else was
thinking of starting the business you
shouldn't be thinking about this or this
because either one you're just going to
be doing on an average level your
strength your awesomeness your power
comes from combining both of those
things together combine all of your
interests make your business personal
show people that you care it's going to
be how you stand out you're going to
have a lot more fun with your company
and you're going to attract the right
kinds of clients people who you love
doing business with and I know it's hard
I know it's risky and I know most people
just think about you know if I get out
there I want to do what everybody else
is doing no that's the safe route I
should only be doing one thing and focus
on that but the real power comes when
you can combine it you look at the
really successful entrepreneurs they had
a deep passion for what they were doing
and they brought themselves into it they
took best practices from other
industries things that they love things
that they knew about and poured it into
the business if you look at the early
days of Apple computer for example Steve
Jobs he loved fonts and typography and
he went to classes university without
paying for without ever getting a degree
in it because he loved learning about
typography and fonts and when he was
designing the Apple computers he said we
have to have beautiful fonts nobody else
was doing this and people thought he was
crazy like why do we why do we care
about fonts and because he combined
those passions he created a product that
was different that was unique that
people cared about and the people bought
so you have to combine all the various
elements the things that make you unique
the things that make you stand out and
pour that into your business and tell
your story and bring as much of those
different elements as possible you're
going to enjoy your company more you're
going to get more ideal customers you're
going to get more passionate energy for
your company you're going to have a lot
more success good luck for those of you
watching like the video please give it a
thumbs up below it makes you want to do
more for you and I want to hear from you
you have a comment about this video
please leave it below if you have a
question
for your company please leave it
underneath I always love seeing those in
the morning when I check in it makes my
day every day really guys appreciate it
so thank you and I'll see you on the
next episode